[Music]
i'm here
to um talk to you uh about
post-liberalism
the first thing i think that it's
important to say about
post-liberalism is the stress on the
word post
it doesn't exactly mean anti-liberalism
and i think now we are faced with a big
anti-liberal
reaction it's much more
trying to say that liberalism
as such is not enough well what do i
mean by liberalism um for the purposes
of this talk and my political philosophy
i'm defining liberalism as a political
position
that wants to start with the isolated
individual the isolated atomic
abstracted individual
not considered in their relationality
or their historical situation
and so on but treats the individual as
basic
and from that follows i think two
alternative values which can get
combined
first of all the idea that you're
promoting as far as possible
the liberty the freedom of choice of the
individual
or else to refer to the talks title
um the idea that you're trying to
promote the happiness
of the individual but happiness of the
individual
in a rather kind of basic um
sort of sensuous uh materialist
um utilitarian sense
so on the one hand we've got what
philosophers call
negative liberty freedom of choice on
the other hand we've got
happiness and both of those things of
course are very important but are they
enough are they sufficient and i would
want to suggest that in fact
um this hasn't always been the dominant
position
even in modern politics liberalism
hasn't had it all its own way and that
besides the importance of emancipation
that means freeing people from
oppression of their
uh just liberties freeing people from
unnecessary suffering there's also been
a pursuit of much more
positive ends ends of community
group identity national identity
educational goals even religious
goals and these have always been part of
the modern story
and these have tended to go along with
promoting relationality
and with promoting the strength
of groups and often the story
of um the the rise of the working
classes
the increase in the strength of working
classes has been
as much to do with these positive goals
as with the
the negative ones it's been about
community
and solidarity uh advancing
certain very very strongly held um
working class um values so
liberalism was never simply
the whole story but i think that um
ever since the roughly speaking the
1970s
we've um started to think that it is the
whole story is that that we can identify
modernity wholesale with liberalism
and exactly why is that well i think
part of the answer is that there's
nothing accidental about this
whatsoever but
a certain group of people have very
deliberately
set out to dominate the narrative
and these are the people who are known
as neo-liberals there's
an american version of neoliberalism but
perhaps
the most basic and dominant version was
an american
uh was an austrian sorry and
um german version now what does
neo-liberalism really mean
well what distinguishes it mainly from
traditional liberalism is the idea that
um it's not enough to just kind of
remove the power of the state and then
automatically you'll get
free market values it's much more the
idea that we need to set up a deliberate
set of laws that put the market first
and put individual liberty um absolutely
first
so that from the the start the
thing that really distinguished
neoliberalism
um was the search for
a new global order that's uh especially
the geneva group of neo-liberals
associated with friedrich hagg
set out deliberately to bypass
democracy to create a new sort of
purely economic global empire
if you like and i say global i say
purely economic but but actually they
envisaged there being
all sorts of international legal
institutions that would
override nations and national democracy
and they were also very keen on the idea
that laws would be mainly made by
judges um rather
than by sovereign parliaments i'm
exaggerating a little
but really um only um
very little there was a kind of
overriding
of national democracy
intended from the outset and the fear
here was primarily a fear of socialism
and of people who want to redistribute
economic resources that was seen as
interfering um with the the purity
of the market so if we now
live in an era where we talk a lot about
globalization
um to some degree that's not an accident
that's not just
something um historically um
inevitable um that this idea that we
need to put the economic first to have
international laws that put the
economic first is something that people
have deliberately pursued
and over the course of time uh if not
originally
that aim for an international economic
empire got
fused with a discourse about
human rights and again the idea that
individual rights must be put above
individual duties or relational
solidarity
that has come more and more to dominate
and the idea then that maybe
the courts especially courts in charge
of human rights
can override um collective decisions
and i think that already in that
marriage between
economic liberty and human rights um
you've got one example of uh
the next thing that i want to talk about
the peculiarity of the
liberal domination of the times in which
we live
an awful lot of people by now have noted
that
ever since the 1970s we've had the very
strange phenomenon that the
the political left has won the cultural
war if we think about uh personal
relations
and sexuality uh and and
and so on the left has won the cultural
war
but the right has won the economic war
overwhelmingly um we've drifted
to um pro-capitalist policies
ever since um that epoch
now again as an awful lot of people have
by now said
this makes much more sense if you stop
thinking
in terms of left and right and if you
say well
basically it's the rich that have won
and
rich people have always been people um
or often anyway have been people if
they're not constrained
who want wealth in order to do just what
they like
in other words um left-wing cultural
liberalism and right being economic
liberalism
are really two halves of the same
picture
and they've tended to converge and
actually if you look at the evidence
from quite early
on um new left cultural liberals
started to drift in a more and more
um pro free market direction so
we've got this combination of
um cultural liberalism
and so-called economic conservatism
although
economic liberalism would be more
the the right way to understand that
now the um extraordinary thing is
that although that combination dominates
of left culture
um right-wing economics there's an awful
lot of evidence that it's the exact
opposite
of what most people want most people
are culturally um really inclined to be
quite conservative they're not
intolerant but they put a very strong
value on
family place inherited tradition
national tradition sometimes on
religious community
on the other hand they do have an
increasing sense
that the the current economic setup is
very very unfair there's increasing
inequality uh absolutely massive
salary um differentials uh an increasing
power of of the super-rich or
unaccountable
who go in for tax evasion
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas